you might think there was a simple
answer to this after all we know how to
say what most things are for like this
or that and people flock to museums like
never before so they must have their
motives but when it comes to art people
get strangely afraid to ask too directly
what it might all be for because well
everyone except you might know the
answer already it's perhaps too obvious
it's too complicated
the result is an awkward silence and a
lot of confusion but maybe it shouldn't
be that hard to say what art is for
maybe we can have a go at describing
certain rather clear purposes to art
here's five things that art might be
able to do for us it's an obvious but
striking fact that the most popular
works of art in the world show pretty
things
happy people flowers in spring blue
skies this is the top-selling postcard
in the world from the Metropolitan
Museum of Art in New York this
enthusiasm for prettiness worries
serious types a lot they wonder have
people forgotten what life's really like
but that seems a misplaced worry
we need pretty things close to us not
because we're in danger of forgetting
the bad stuff or because terrible
problems weigh so heavily on us
that were in danger of slipping into
despair and depression
that's why prettiness matters it's an
emblem of Hope which is an achievement
prettiness those flowers and blue skies
and kids in meadows is hope bottled and
preserved waiting for us when we need it
the world often requires us to put on a
cheerful facade but beneath the surface
there's a lot of sadness and regret that
we can't express from fear of seeming
weird or a loser
one thing art can do is reassure us of
the normality of pain it can be sad with
and for us some of the world's greatest
works of art have been loved for their
capacity to make the pain that's inside
all of us publicly visible and available
like putting on a sad piece of music
somber works of art
don't have to depress us rather they can
give us the welcome feeling the pain is
part of the human condition art fights
the false optimism of commercial society
it's there to remind us with dignity
that every good life has extraordinary
amounts of confusion suffering
loneliness and distress within it and
that therefore we should never aggravate
sadness by feeling we must be freakish
simply for experiencing it quite a lot
all of us are a little unbalanced in
some way we're too intellectual too
emotional too masculine or too feminine
to calm or too excitable the art we love
is frequently something we're drawn to
because it compensates us for what we
lack it counterbalances us when we moved
by a work of art it may be because it
contains concentrated doses of qualities
we need more of in our lives
perhaps it's full of the serenity we
admire but don't have enough of perhaps
it's got the tenderness we longed for
but that our jobs and relationships are
currently lacking or perhaps it's
diffused with a pain and drama we've had
a stifle but want to get in touch with
sometimes a whole society falls in love
with a certain style in art because it's
trying to rebalance itself like France
in the late 18th century that wanted de
vivre is a corrective to its decadence
or Britain in the 19th century that look
to the pre-raphaelites to counter the
effects of brutal industrialization the
art a country or a person calls
beautiful gives you vital clues as to
what's missing in them it's in the power
of art to help us be more rounded more
balanced and more sane the media is
constantly giving us hints about what's
glamorous and important art also tells
us about what's glamorous and important
but fortunately given that you weren't
invited again to the Oscars this year it
usually picks on some very different
things
Albrecht Durer makes grass look
glamorous John Constable draws our
attention to the skies
van Gogh reminds us that oranges are
worth paying attention to Marcel Duchamp
challenges us to look again at the
seemingly mundane
these artists aren't falsely
glamourizing things that are better
ignored that justly teasing out a value
that's been neglected by a world with it
deeply distorted an unfair sense of what
truly matters art returns glamour to its
rightful place highlighting what's
genuinely worth appreciating nothing
seems further from good art than
propaganda the sort encouraging you to
fight or what government to support but
one way to think about art is that it is
a sort of propaganda in a sense of a
tool that motivates and energizes you
for a cause only its propaganda on
behalf of some of the most important and
nicest emotions and attitudes in the
world which it uses its skills to make
newly appealing and accessible it might
be propaganda about the simple life or
about the need to broaden one's horizons
or about a more playful tender approach
to life it's a force that stands up for
the best sides of human nature and gives
them a platform and an authority in a
noisy distracted world for too long
arts attracted a little too much
reverence and mystique for its own good
in its presence with like someone
meeting a very famous person we get
stiff and lose our spontaneity
we should relax around it as we already
do with music and learn to use it for
what it's really meant for as a constant
source of support and encouragement for
our better selves
you